Pendant les 18 prochaines minutes, je vais vous emmener en voyage.
Et c'est un voyage que vous et moi avons entreprenons depuis de nombreuses années,
et qui a débuté il y a environ 50 ans, quand des humains ont quitté notre planète pour la première fois.
Et pendant ces 50 années, non seulement nous avons littéralement, physiquement posé le pied sur la Lune,
mais nous avons envoyé des engins spatiaux robotisés vers toutes les planètes (chacune des huit)
et nous avons atterri sur des astéroïdes, nous avons rejoint des comètes,
et au moment où je vous parle, un de nos vaisseaux est en route vers Pluton,
le corps céleste connu auparavant comme étant une planète.
Et toutes ces missions robotisées font partie d'un voyage humain plus vaste :
un voyage pour comprendre quelque chose, pour avoir une idée de notre place dans le cosmos,
pour saisir quelque chose de nos origines, et comment la Terre, notre planète,
et nous, qui vivons dessus, avons existé.
Et de tous les endroits du système solaire où nous pourrions aller
pour chercher des réponses à ce genre de question,
il y a Saturne. Nous sommes déjà allés sur Saturne
(on a visité Saturne au début des années 80)
mais nos recherches sur Saturne sont devenues beaucoup plus approfondies et détaillées
depuis que la sonde spatiale Cassini, après avoir traversé l'espace interplanétaire
pendant sept ans, a glissé dans l'orbite de Saturne pendant l'été 2004,
devenant à ce jour le poste avancé robotisé le plus éloigné
que l'humanité n?ait jamais établi autour du Soleil.
Cela étant, le système de Saturne est un système planétaire riche.
Il propose du mystère, des perspectives scientifiques, et manifestement une splendeur sans égale,
et la recherche sur ce système a une portée cosmique exceptionnelle.
En fait, rien qu'avec l'étude des anneaux, nous en apprenons énormément
sur les disques d'étoiles et de gaz que nous appelons galaxies spirales.
Et voici une magnifique photo de la nébuleuse d'Andromède,
qui est la galaxie spirale la plus grande et la plus proche de la Voie Lactée.
et ensuite nous avons une superbe image composite de la galaxie du Tourbillon,
prise par le télescope spatial Hubble.
Et donc le voyage vers Saturne fait en réalité partie (et c'est également la métaphore)
d'un voyage humain beaucoup plus large
afin de comprendre l'interconnectivité de tout ce qui nous entoure,
et comment les humains s'intègrent dans ce tableau.
Et je souffre de ne pas pouvoir vous dire tout ce qu'on a appris grâce à Cassini --
Je ne peux pas vous montrer toutes les belles photos que nous avons prises
depuis deux ans et demi, tout simplement parce que je n'ai pas le temps.
Donc je vais me concentrer sur deux des sujets les plus passionnants
qui ont débouché de cette mission d'exploration capitale
que nous menons autour de Saturne,
et que nous avons menée depuis deux ans et demi.
Saturne est accompagnée d'une importante collection de lunes très diverses.
En taille, leur diamètre va de quelques kilomètres à la largeur des États-Unis.
D'ailleurs, la plupart des photos magnifiques que nous avons prises de Saturne
montrent Saturne accompagnée de certaines de ses lunes. Voici Saturne avec Dioné,
et là on voit Saturne avec les anneaux sur la tranche,
ce qui vous montre à quel point ils sont fins verticalement, avec la lune Encelade.
Maintenant, parmi les 47 lunes que possède Saturne, deux sont remarquables.
Ce sont Titan et Encelade. Titan est la plus grande lune de Saturne,
et avant que Cassini n'y arrive,
c'était la plus vaste étendue unique de territoire inexploré
qu'il nous restait dans le système solaire.
Et c'est un objet qui intrigue depuis longtemps les gens qui observent les planètes.
Il a une atmosphère très étendue, très épaisse,
et en fait on pensait que son environnement de surface
ressemblait davantage à ce que l'on a ici, sur Terre,
ou du moins à ce que nous avons eu dans le passé, que pour n'importe quel autre objet du système solaire.
Son atmosphère est principalement composée de molécules d'azote, comme ce que vous respirez ici dans cette pièce,
sauf que son atmosphère est imprégnée
de matières organiques simples telles que le méthane, le propane et l'éthane.
Et ces molécules, en altitude dans l'atmosphère de Titan
sont brisées, et leurs substrats se rassemblent pour constituer des particules de brume.
Cette brume est partout, elle est totalement globale et recouvre Titan.
Et c'est pour cela qu'on ne peut pas voir la surface
avec nos yeux, dans la région visible du spectre.
Mais on a émis la conjecture que ces particules de brume,
avant que l'on arrive là-bas avec Cassini, pendant des milliards et des milliards d'années
ont doucement dérivé vers la surface et recouvert la surface
d'une épaisse vase organique.
Comme l'équivalent, l'équivalent sur Titan du goudron, du pétrole, ou de n'importe quoi -- on ne savait pas quoi.
Mais c'était ce que l'on soupçonnait. Et ces molécules,
surtout le méthane et l'éthane, peuvent être liquides aux températures de surface de Titan
Et donc il s'avère que le méthane est à Titan ce que l'eau est à la Terre.
il peut se condenser dans l'atmosphère,
et donc le fait d'admettre cette caractéristique a mis au premier plan
tout un monde de possibilités étranges. Vous pouvez avoir des nuages de méthane, ok,
et au-dessus de ces nuages il y a ces centaines de kilomètres de brume
qui empêchent tout rayon de soleil de parvenir à la surface.
La température de surface est d'environs - 180 °C.
Mais malgré ce froid, de la pluie pourrait tomber sur la surface de Titan.
En faisant sur Titan ce que la pluie fait sur Terre, elle creuse des ravins, elle crée des rivières
et des cataractes. Elle peut créer des canyons, elle peut former des flaques dans les bassins larges et les cratères.
Elle peut laver la vase des hauts sommets montagneux et des collines
et l'emporter dans les terres basses. Alors, prenez le temps de réfléchir une minute.
Essayez d'imaginer à quoi pourrait ressembler la surface de Titan.
Il fait sombre -- le soleil de midi sur Titan est aussi sombre qu'un profond crépuscule sur Terre
Il fait froid, c'est étrange, il y a du brouillard,
il se peut qu'il pleuve, et vous pourriez être là,
sur les berges du lac Michigan, débordant de diluant pour peinture.
C'est ainsi que nous voyions la surface de Titan avant qu'on y arrive avec Cassini,
et je peux vous dire que ce qu'on a trouvé sur Titan, bien que les détails soient différents,
est tout aussi fascinant que cette histoire.
Et pour nous ça a été (pour les gens de Cassini)
ça a été comme une aventure de Jules Verne devenue réalité.
Comme je l'ai dit, il y a une atmosphère épaisse et très étendue.
Voici une image de Titan rétroéclairé par le soleil, avec les magnifiques anneaux en toile de fond.
et encore une autre lune ici...
Je ne sais même pas laquelle c'est. C'est une atmosphère très étendue.
Nous avons des instruments sur Cassini qui peuvent voir jusqu'à la surface
à travers cette atmosphère, et mon système photo en fait partie.
Et nous avons pris des photos comme celle-ci.
Et ce que vous voyez ce sont des régions claires et sombres, et on ne pouvait pas aller beaucoup plus loin.
C'était tellement déroutant, on n'arrivait pas à identifier ce que l'on voyait sur Titan.
Quand on regarde de plus près cette région, on commence à voir des choses
comme des canaux sinueux, qu'on ne connaissait pas. On voit quelques objets circulaires.
On a découvert plus tard que ceci est en fait un cratère,
mais il y a très peu de cratères à la surface de Titan,
ce qui veut dire que c'est une surface très jeune.
Et certaines structures semblent être de nature tectonique.
Elles semblent avoir été écartées l'une de l'autre.
A chaque fois que vous voyez quelque chose de linéaire sur une planète,
cela signifie qu'il y a eu une fracture, comme une faille.
Et donc elle a été altérée par la tectonique.
Mais nous n'arrivions pas à donner un sens à nos images,
jusqu'à ce que six mois après l'entrée en orbite,
un événement se produise, que beaucoup ont considéré
comme le point culminant des recherches de Cassini sur Titan.
Et il s'agissait du déploiement de la sonde Huygens,
la sonde européenne Huygens que Cassini a transportée
pendant sept ans à travers le système solaire. Nous l'avons déployée dans l'atmosphère de Titan,
il lui a fallu deux heures et demie pour descendre, et elle s'est posée sur la surface.
Et je veux juste mettre l'accent sur l'importance d'un tel événement.
Il s'agit d'un dispositif fabriqué de la main de l'homme,
et il s'est posé à l'extrémité du système solaire pour la première fois dans l'histoire de l'humanité.
C'est si important que d'après moi,
c'est un événement qui aurait dû être fêté
avec une parade et des jets de confettis dans toutes les villes des États-Unis et d'Europe,
et malheureusement, ça n'a pas été le cas.
(Rires)
C'était important pour une autre raison. Il s'agit d'une mission internationale,
et cet événement a été fêté en Europe, en Allemagne,
et les présentations des festivités ont été faites avec des accents anglais,
et des accents américains, et des accents allemands, français, italiens et néerlandais.
C'était une démonstration émouvante de ce que les mots
"Nations Unies" sont censés signifier:
une véritable union de nations réunies dans un effort considérable pour le bien.
Et dans ce cas, ils s'agissait d'une entreprise colossale pour explorer une planète
et parvenir à comprendre un système planétaire
qui avait été hors d'atteinte durant toute l'histoire de l'humanité,
et maintenant les humains étaient parvenus à le toucher.
Donc c'était... je veux dire, j'ai des frissons rien que d'en parler,
c'était un événement extraordinairement chargé d'émotion,
et c'est quelque chose que personnellement je n'oublierai jamais, et vous ne devriez pas non plus.
(Applaudissements)
Enfin bref, la sonde a enregistré des mesures de l'atmosphère pendant sa descente
et elle a aussi pris des photos panoramiques.
Et je ne saurais vous dire ce qu'on a ressenti la première fois qu'on a vu ces photos
de la surface de Titan provenant de la sonde. Voici ce qu'on a vu.
Et ce fut un choc, parce que c'était tout ce que nous voulions
que soient ces autres photos prises en orbite.
le schéma était clair, c'était un schéma géologique.
C'est un schéma de drainage dendritique qui ne peut être formé que par l'écoulement de liquides.
Et on peut suivre ces canaux
et on peut voir comment tous, ils convergent.
Et ils convergent vers ce canal ici, qui s'écoule dans cette région.
Ce que vous voyez c'est un littoral.
Etait-ce un littoral de liquides ? On ne savait pas.
Mais c'est une sorte de littoral.
Cette photo est prise à 16 kilomètres.
Voici la photo prise à huit kilomètres, d'accord ? A nouveau, le littoral.
Ok, donc 16 kilomètres, 8 kilomètres... c'est en gros l'altitude d'un avion.
Si vous survoliez les États-Unis en avion,
vous voleriez à ces altitudes.
Donc c'est l'image que vous verriez depuis le hublot de Titanian Airlines
pendant votre survol de la surface de Titan. (Rires)
Et puis finalement, la sonde s'est immobilisée sur la surface,
et je vais vous montrer, mesdames et messieurs,
la première photo jamais prise depuis la surface d'une lune du système solaire extérieur.
Et voici l'horizon, d'accord ?
Ça ce sont probablement des cailloux d'eau gelée, pas vrai ?
(Applaudissements)
Et manifestement elle s'est posée dans l'une de ces régions plates et sombres.
et elle n'a pas coulé hors de notre vue. Donc on ne s'est pas posé dans du liquide.
Ce sur quoi la sonde s'est posée, c'était en gros
l'équivalent sur Titan d'un banc de boue.
C'est un sol non consolidé qui est imprégné de méthane liquide.
Et il est probable que ces composants
aient été charriés depuis les hauteurs de Titan
le long de ces canaux que nous avons vus,
et se soient écoulés pendant des milliards d'années pour remplir des bassins de basse altitude.
Et c'est là-dedans que s'est posée la sonde Huygens.
Mais pourtant, il n'y avait aucun indice dans nos photos,
ou même dans les images de Huygens, de la présence de larges étendues ouvertes de liquides.
Où étaient-elles ? C'est devenu encore plus déroutant quand nous avons découvert des dunes.
Ok, donc voici notre film de la région équatoriale de Titan,
qui montre ces dunes. Ce sont des dunes de 100 mètres de haut,
distantes de quelques kilomètres,
et il y en a sur des kilomètres et des kilomètres.
Il y en a des centaines, jusqu'à 1500 ou 2000 kms de dunes.
C'est le désert du Sahara de Titan.
C'est clairement un endroit très sec, autrement il n'y aurait pas de dunes.
Encore une fois, il était déroutant qu'il n'y ait pas d'étendues de liquide,
jusqu'à ce que finalement on trouve des lacs dans les régions polaires.
Et il y a une zone lacustre dans la région polaire du sud de Titan.
Elle fait à peu près la taille du lac Ontario.
Et puis, il y a seulement une semaine et demie,
nous avons survolé le pôle Nord de Titan et découvert, à nouveau,
nous en avons découvert une ici de la taille de la mer Caspienne.
Donc il semble que les liquides, pour une raison que nous ne connaissons pas,
ou du moins à cette saison, se trouvent aux pôles de Titan.
Et je pense que vous conviendrez que nous avons découvert que Titan
est un endroit extraordinaire, mystique. C'est exotique, extraterrestre, et pourtant ça ressemble étrangement à la Terre,
et possède des formations géologiques similaires à la Terre,
ainsi qu'une diversité géographique exceptionnelle,
et que c'est un monde fascinant qui ne rivalise dans tout le système solaire
en complexité et en richesse qu'avec la Terre elle-même.
Et donc maintenant nous allons sur Encelade. Encelade est une petite lune,
elle fait environ un dixième de la taille de titan, et vous pouvez la voir ici à côté de l'Angleterre.
C'est juste pour vous montrer la taille; ce n'est pas une menace.
(Rires)
Et Encelade est très blanche, elle est très brillante,
et sa surface est manifestement déchirée par des failles,
c'est un corps très actif sur le plan géologique.
Mais le filon principal des découvertes sur Encelade
a été trouvé au pôle Sud (et nous voyons le pôle Sud en ce moment)
où nous avons découvert ce système de failles.
Et elles sont d'une couleur différente parce que leur composition est différente.
Elles sont recouvertes. Ces failles sont couvertes de matières organiques.
Qui plus est, cette région tout entière, la région du pôle Sud,
a des températures élevées. C'est l'endroit le plus chaud de la planète, de cette étendue.
C'est aussi étrange que de découvrir sur Terre que l'Antarctique est plus chaud que les tropiques.
Et puis, après avoir pris d'autres photos, nous avons découvert
que de ces failles sont issues des jets de fines particules de glace
qui se prolongent sur des centaines de kilomètres dans l'espace.
et quand on rajoute un code couleur à cette image pour faire ressortir les niveaux de lumière moins visibles,
on voit que ces jets alimentent une crinière
qui, on le voit sur d'autres images, s'étend sur des milliers de kilomètres
dans l'espace au-dessus d'Encelade.
Mon équipe et moi-même avons examiné des images comme celle-ci,
et comme celle-ci, et nous avons pensé aux autres résultats de Cassini.
Et nous sommes arrivés à la conclusion
que ces jets pourraient sortir de poches
d'eau liquide sous la surface d'Encelade.
Et donc nous avons peut-être de l'eau liquide, des matières organiques et un excès de chaleur.
En d'autres termes, nous sommes peut-être tombés
sur le Saint Graal de l'exploration planétaire de l'âge moderne.
Ou en d'autres termes, un environnement qui peut potentiellement accueillir des organismes vivants.
Et je pense que je n'ai pas besoin de vous dire que la découverte de la vie
ailleurs dans notre système solaire,
que ce soit sur Encelade ou ailleurs,
aurait des implications scientifiques et culturelles colossales.
Parce que si nous pouvions démontrer que la Genèse a eu lieu
non pas une, mais deux fois, de manière indépendante dans notre système solaire,
cela signifie, par déduction, qu'elle a eu lieu un nombre prodigieux de fois
à travers l'univers et son histoire forte de 13,7 milliards d'années.
Pour l'instant, la Terre est encore la seule planète qui à notre connaissance regorge de vie.
Elle est précieuse, elle est unique,
elle est encore, pour l'instant, le seul foyer que nous ayons connu.
Et si certains d'entre vous étaient vigilants et lucides pendant les années 60
(et on vous pardonnerait si vous ne l'étiez pas, hein)
vous vous rappelleriez cette très célèbre photo
prise par les astronautes d'Apollo VIII en 1968.
C'était la première fois que la Terre était prise en photo de l'espace,
et cela a eu un impact énorme sur notre perception de notre place dans l'univers,
et notre perception de notre responsabilité dans la protection de notre propre planète.
Eh bien nous, avec Cassini, nous avons fait une première équivalente,
une photo qu'aucun oeil humain n'a jamais vue auparavant.
C'est une éclipse totale de Soleil, vue depuis l'autre côté de Saturne.
Et dans cette photo d'une beauté irréelle
on voit les principaux anneaux rétroéclairés par le Soleil,
on voit l'image réfractée du Soleil
et on voit cet anneau créé, en réalité,
par les émanations d'Encelade.
Mais comme si ça n'était pas assez grandiose, on peut apercevoir cette image magnifique,
une vue de notre propre planète,
bercée par les bras des anneaux de Saturne.
Maintenant, il y a quelque chose de profondément émouvant
à se voir ainsi de loin,
à capturer la vue de notre petite planète aux océans bleus
dans les cieux d'autres mondes.
Et cela, et la perspective de nous-mêmes que nous acquérons par là,
c'est peut-être, en définitive, la plus belle récompense que nous obtenons
de ce voyage de découverte entamé il y a un demi-siècle.
Et merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements).